[Musique]
le port du masque est il dangereux pour
notre santé
c'est ce que laissent entendre plusieurs
publications sur le web ce texte
alarmiste a été partagée à plus de 4000
reprises
il suggère que ceux qui portent un
masque s'intoxiquent sans le savoir que
le fait de porter des masques peut mener
à des pertes de conscience
il ya des risques d'hypoxie cérébrale le
gouvernement qui va qui veut dire qu'ils
vont oser dire de nos suggéré de porter
un masque
je dis non ça pas de prix respirer
librement les proxys survient quand le
taux d'oxygène dans le sang des sens où
le minimum requis pour le métier des
fonctions vitales
conséquence mauvais fonctionnement ou
arrêt des organes le cerveau étant
généralement le premier a flanché
mais n'ayez crainte si l'hypoxie peut
survenir parfois au sommet d'une haute
montagne ou en plongée sous marine
ce n'est généralement pas le cas quand
on porte un masque ça fait 25 ans que je
fais des soins intensifs et j'ai porté
ces masques et là j'ai vu un paquet de
personnes autour de moi à porter et
gérer eu de cody proxy et ça pose
produire physiologiquement la physique
de l'hypoxie et de ces masques l'un des
ports compétitifs et selon
l'infectiologue épidémiologistes
carabine couach tous les modèles de
masques sont précisément conçu pour
permettre une circulation d'air et de
gaz selon elle les masques de tissus ou
de procédure ne cause aucune hypoxie et
sont faits pour arrêter les grosses
gouttes l'est tout en laissant passer
les molécules d'oxygène et de co2 cela
dit madame couach note que les masques
de type n 95 cause parfois une hypoxie
relative mais c'est un masque non
recommandés pour la population générale
que porte uniquement les travailleurs de
la santé qui s'assure justement de se
relayer et de ne pas porter de masque au
delà des seuils recommandés par les
autorités sanitaires
les rares cas où des risques d'hypoxie
pourrait survenir selon la pneumologue
mathieu simon concerne le port prolongé
du masque chez les personnes souffrant
d'une fibrose pulmonaire d'un emphysème
sévère ou ayant une résistance
importante à la respiration des
conditions qui sont de toute façon
incompatible avec le port du masque
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur mon
dossier là tu aller lire mon article sur
notre page web
et n'oubliez pas notre émission est
diffusée les samedis dimanches
souricière des allers simples
[Musique]